salut mon nom est nabil
j'espère que vous m'entendez bien que ma
tête chauve
n'est pas trop brillante sur la vidéo donc avant d'
entrer dans la conversation
un peu de contexte sur moi et
le sujet bien sûr
alors euh tout ce que vous devez savoir  à propos de moi,
c'est quand je ne fais pas de recherches et que je ne lis pas
sur la
productivité et les affaires de la psychologie du cerveau,
j'écris sur ces sujets, généralement des
articles que je publie en ligne
et le sujet d'aujourd'hui s'appelle le
t-shirt invisible, évidemment, il ne s'agit pas
d'un t-shirt,
c'est  en fait, pourquoi certaines informations
sont invisibles pour notre cerveau et
comment changer cela,
en d'autres termes, comment sélectionner le
type d'informations auxquelles
nous prêtons inconsciemment attention, en
particulier
cela pourrait être des opportunités avant, alors
commençons par une question rapide
avez-vous  vous vous êtes retrouvé dans une pièce ou
au bureau à la recherche de quelque chose que
vous savez être juste devant vous,
mais vous pouvez le voir, vous ne pouvez pas le trouver, il
pourrait s'agir d'un casque, de
votre téléphone ou d'un ordinateur portable, d'un
dossier papier  quoi qu'il en soit,
alors pour moi, comme vous l'avez peut-être deviné,
cela a toujours été un t-shirt,
cela a commencé pendant mon enfance et se
produit encore aujourd'hui la
dernière fois que cela s'est produit, c'était deux ans
avant la couronne,
j'étais chez mes parents et à
chaque fois  je suis dans la
maison de mes parents je redeviens l'enfant que j'étais
alors de toute façon j'étais là-
bas je me préparais à aller prendre
un café avec mes amis qui
m'attendaient dehors dans leur voiture
donc j'ai dû me dépêcher  mais ils n'ont pas
trouvé mon t-shirt c'était un t-shirt noir
avec un personnage de dragon ball
dessus je ne l'ai pas trouvé j'ai dû me dépêcher
alors j'ai fait ce que je fais le mieux qui était
maman tu as vu mon noir  t-shirt avec
vegeta dessus ma mère n'a aucune idée de qui
vegeta est
pourtant elle entre instantanément trouve le
t-shirt
et elle s'en va bien
ce n'était pas la seule chose intéressante
qui s'est produite ce soir-là
plus tard je discutais que j'avais  une
conversation avec mes amis
et nous parlions d'
opportunités d'affaires à l'époque
m  y amis voulaient lancer une entreprise
et ils essayaient de comprendre quelles
opportunités ils
pouvaient saisir à l'époque ouais et
euh alors nous avons parlé de linkedin instagram
facebook whatsapp airbnb
toutes ces entreprises prospères et
nous avons pensé que euh ces
entreprises en fait ce qu'elles  ont-ils
vu un besoin d'une opportunité avant tout le
monde, puis
ils ont apporté une solution pour cela, c'est
pourquoi
ils ont réussi, puis nous avons
conclu qu'en
fait, les opportunités sont partout,
elles sont devant nous,
mais nous tous et tout ce que nous devons  faire pour
réussir c'est
voir la bonne opportunité puis la
saisir comme le t-shirt maintenant
quand on y pense que ce soit un
t-shirt ou une opportunité
c'est exactement la même chose pour votre
cerveau c'est l'information
juste et il s'avère que notre cerveau  ont
une capacité limitée à traiter l'
information
et nous vivons dans un monde où tout
est information en gros vous vous réveillez
le matin
sur votre téléphone vous avez des dizaines de
ma  ses messages vous avez
des médias sociaux vous avez youtube vous avez
toutes ces applications à l'
extérieur vous avez des publicités vous avez votre
conversation quotidienne au travail avec la famille
tout cela est une information
juste c'est écrasant pour nos cerveaux
c'est pourquoi nos cerveaux ne sont pas
submergés les chats en
coupent certains  cette information, certaines
personnes l'appellent
certains, je veux dire spécialiste pour être précis,
appelez-la
euh attention sélective et cette
attention sélective est réalisée
par un mécanisme spécifique appelé
le système d'activation réticulaire et
c'est le seul mot scientifique que
j'utilise euh ce soir et alors
qu'est-ce qui est  ce système d'activation réticulaire
qui nous fait sélectionner des informations
maintenant pour comprendre comment cela fonctionne imaginez
que votre attention est une boîte de nuit d'accord
ce qu'il y a devant chaque boîte de nuit
exactement un gars de la sécurité de la boîte de nuit le gars
qui sélectionne qui entre et qui
ne passe généralement pas par leur  chaussures de
toute façon le système d'activation réticulaire
est le gars de la sécurité de la discothèque
de votre attention d'accord alors quelle est la
différence  ce
qu'il y a une différence entre le
gars de la sécurité de la boîte de nuit et le
système d'activation réticulaire, c'est que
vous pouvez réellement négocier avec votre
système d'activation réticulaire,
alors comment faites-vous cela, surtout que
votre système d'activation réticulaire fait
partie de votre esprit subconscient
en d'autres termes  comment dites-vous à votre
subconscient à quel type d'
information il devrait prêter attention
alors d'accord euh
la façon dont vous le faites en fait d'
accord posons une meilleure question ici
comment convaincre quelqu'un d'une question plus facile
plutôt comment convaincre
quelqu'un que
vous avez habituellement  vous devez faire deux
choses d'abord vous devez parler la même
langue
parce que bonne chance pour convaincre quelqu'un si
vous ne parlez pas la même langue
et ensuite vous devez faire la deuxième
chose est que vous devez rendre votre
proposition
intéressante pour votre homologue
donc  vous devez trouver ce qui pourrait être
intéressant
pour votre homologue par exemple si vous
voulez
bien travailler avec moi vous avez un meilleur
ch  ance de moi acceptant si vous suggérez
que nous en parlions
en mangeant de la pizza, pourquoi est-ce parce que
j'aime la pizza et que je suis
intéressé à manger de la pizza, donc
si vous proposez une suggestion disant d'
accord, faisons cela et mangeons de la
pizza en même temps  Je serais intéressé,
donc en fait, vous faites exactement cela avec
votre cerveau, vous devez parler le même
langage que votre subconscient
et vous devez être convaincant, vous
devez donc
savoir ce qui pourrait être intéressant pour
votre subconscient,
alors commençons  avec le langage bien,
le langage que votre esprit subconscient
parle
est en fait un mot qui est des
objectifs d'accord maintenant vous pourriez vous demander pourquoi
est-ce
parce qu'en fait les objectifs sont incarnés dans
le comportement
humain les êtres humains sont des machines à fixer et à
atteindre des objectifs vous vous réveillez le
matin  tu vas dans la salle de bain c'est le
but un
but deux tu vas dans la cuisine tu prends
un café le thé du petit déjeuner c'est cool aussi
puis tu retournes dans ta chambre va trois
tu t'habilles
va va fou  r vous avez l'idée que c'est comme
où que vous soyez, vous vous déplacez du
point a au point b
atteindre l'établissement d'objectifs et atteindre un
objectif donc l'établissement d'objectifs est le langage que
votre esprit subconscient est un langage
plutôt que vous
que votre esprit subconscient peut parler
et  comprenez bien
alors comment sélectionner des informations en fonction
d'un objectif
peut être délicat, ce que vous faites est correct d'
abord, vous définissez le type d'
informations auxquelles vous voulez
accorder plus d'attention, par exemple
vous voulez
repérer plus de
beaux bâtiments ou monuments autour du
ville ou de
très beaux endroits pris pour prendre
une photo de choses comme ça donc votre
objectif serait
bien je serais vous voudriez devenir un
photographe décent ou je voudrais commencer une
page de médias sociaux avec des
photographies et des photos de ma ville
ou ailleurs, par exemple,
mes amis qui essayaient de lancer une
entreprise,
ils recherchaient des opportunités et
ils pouvaient se fixer un objectif en
disant d'accord dans six mois, je veux
démarrer
une entreprise alimentaire  ss désolé j'aime la nourriture
une entreprise dans le domaine alimentaire
c'est un objectif
donc c'est votre première étape la première étape est de
vous fixer un
objectif lié aux informations que
vous voulez que
votre cerveau commence à attraper puis vient
la
partie la plus délicate du  processus
qui convainc votre
cerveau, nous devons donc inverser la question comme nous l'
avons fait avec moi
et pizza à droite, la question devient
ce qui pourrait être intéressant
pour votre subconscient et c'est
aussi un mot
qui est la survie exactement
votre subconscient l'un de ses principaux
euh les
fonctions sont de vous garder en vie et de
savoir que d'accord maintenant, nous pourrions nous demander
comment pouvez-vous simplement prendre un objectif
et le rendre essentiel pour la survie, cela
semble peu probable, en
fait, il y a une
caractéristique spécifique de votre
subconscient que vous  peut tirer parti de
ce qui est
et c'est très important votre
esprit subconscient ne fait pas de
différence entre ce que vous imaginez
et l'expérience de la vie réelle pour votre
subconscient m  ind c'est exactement la même
chose d'
accord, alors comment est-ce utile,
c'est utile parce qu'en fait, si vous
choisissez un objectif
et que vous vous imaginez le faire tous les
jours pendant cinq ou dix minutes, quel que soit le
jour, vous vous imaginez le faire au
fil du temps, votre subconscient
pensera  que
cet objectif fait partie de qui vous êtes et que
la partie
de l'instinct de survie est de préserver
votre image de soi
qui vous êtes fondamentalement, donc si cet objectif
devient une partie
de vous, comme la réalisation de cet objectif devient
en quelque sorte un instinct de survie
et puis  votre subconscient
serait aha,
je devrais probablement accorder plus d'attention aux
beaux monuments ou aux belles rues
ou
je ne connais pas un arbre pour prendre une photo,
il pourrait accorder
plus d'attention aux idées commerciales ou aux
idées d'applications ou aux articles sur Internet
qui  sont
liés à ce que vous voulez faire cela pourrait
être plus dans
votre subconscient pourrait être
intéressé si vous cherchez un emploi
votre subconscient pourrait commencer à
saisir
les opportunités d'emploi o  r des idées sur la
création de votre propre travail en
fait, c'est le but et ensuite
vous commencez et puis et c'est à quel point désolé
et c'est ainsi que vous commencez à voir
les informations invisibles les informations auparavant
invisibles
maintenant vous pouvez les voir parce que
votre esprit subconscient est votre
activation réticulaire  le système
va comme aha je peux je dois laisser
cette
information bien, donc la
dernière question maintenant est-ce que cela
fonctionne
bien euh c'est en fait comme ça que je suis arrivé ici
euh en génétique l'
anglais est ma troisième langue je n'ai
jamais fait de
formation à la prise de parole en public ou
autre  d'autres événements officiels,
mais j'ai passé quelques mois, je me suis fixé un
objectif qu'il
fait parler en public et j'ai passé
quelques mois à
m'imaginer faire le discours
correctement, puis un jour j'étais dans ce
métro
et je faisais défiler  linkedin et
puis tout à coup je me suis arrêté
j'ai vu tedxustp
donc c'était un t-shirt invisible que
j'ai vu j'étais comme euh-huh
je pouvais en fait euh envoyer euh leur envoyer un
in  vitation
parce que ces gars
organisent essentiellement des événements de prise de parole en public,
il serait donc logique de se connecter à eux
mettre mon téléphone dans ma poche la vie continue
20 minutes plus tard
je sors je vais au gymnase et je
prends mon téléphone pour en mettre  musique allumée pour
se préparer à l'entraînement
, puis j'ai vu deux notifications
dont l'une était tedx disant bonjour merci pour
la
connexion euh euh nous vous souhaitons une bonne journée
alors j'ai souri mettre de la musique et mettre mon
téléphone dans ma poche a
pris exactement  deux étapes j'ai gelé
mon esprit a attiré une idée sur moi qui était d'
attendre une minute
ces gars sont actifs ce qui signifie que si je
leur envoie un message
ils pourraient le voir et ils pourraient
probablement répondre
que c'était le deuxième t-shirt invisible alors
je leur ai écrit
hey  les gars, euh, si vous
cherchez un conférencier
ayant des intérêts dans les
affaires de productivité en psychologie des sciences du cerveau
ouais vous savez que vous pouvez euh faites le moi savoir
et me voilà donc avant
euh avant de vous quitter je veux que vous vous
souveniez que
je veux vous en dire trois  les choses vont bien donc
t  La première
est que vous ne contrôlez pas entièrement votre
attention, la
plupart des informations auxquelles vous prêtez
attention,
vous faites attention inconsciemment,
deuxièmement, vous pouvez changer cela, vous pouvez
changer cela en vous fixant un objectif spécifique
et en vous imaginant travailler sur
cet objectif tous les jours.
mieux, même si vous pouvez travailler sur cet objectif
un peu chaque jour,
vous commencerez à voir plus
d'informations que vous voulez voir
réellement,
donc en d'autres termes, lorsque vous
communiquez vos objectifs
à votre subconscient, vous voyez
le  invisible
et troisième et dernier merci beaucoup
pour votre écoute
et bonne journée c'était nabil
bye merci
[Musique]
vous